it's my intention this evening to hold
up for you a mirror
a mirror that you can look into and
examine for yourself the breadth
and the depth of your goals and the
commitment and the discipline
and the perseverance you bring to the
pursuit of those goals
it's my intention this evening to create
within you a little dissonance
a little disharmony a little
dissatisfaction
which is the essence of motivation
so for the balance of the evening you
begin to ask yourself some hard
questions
and maybe you'll be satisfied with the
answers
and maybe you won't
i'm not going to tell you anything you
don't already know
just hope to maybe present it to you a
little differently
perhaps in a manner that you haven't
seen or heard before
now you may sit there and say well vince
nothing new
[Music]
come on not the same old same old
not the same old motivational stuff
every time we come to a meeting like
this
well let me ask you a question how many
diets does it take to get down the
weight you'd like to be at
just one the one you stick with
how many times you have to reorganize
your office your desk
your approach to your business your
profession your career before you begin
to see some of the results you'd like to
see
just one the one you commit to
and stick with
and how many personal growth programs do
you have to take on
before you begin to see some of the
changes in your personal life you'd like
to see
just one the one you commit to
and discipline yourself to stick with